best animated short animated in short I
think someone's making fun of us
no no somebody's making fun of you is
you're smaller than me
sounds not about me you got on heels I'm
not gonna do this not here okay
listen when I was a kid we called these
things cartoons we didn't know how much
genius and craft it takes to make each
little perfect jewel of a film we just
knew we loved them tonight's nominees
for best animated short give us five
more jewels to love the bigger picture
Daisy Jacobs and Christopher he's the
dam keeper
Robert condo and dice Tsutsumi feast
Patrick Osbourne and Christina read me
and my molten toriel Cove a single life
yura so friends all right and the Oscar
goes to feast pageant Edoardo Christina
read
oh man that the sorts are so freakin
amazing this year thank you the Academy
for recognizing short animated films
they're my favorite thing to make and
watch thanks John Lasseter at Catmull
and Andrew Milstein for letting me make
my film - Geoff Turley my production
designer who's the best painter alive
and he's the reason the short looks so
great and the rest of the crew it does
an animation you guys are the best
best in the business and to my mom and
dad I love you and everybody back in
Cincinnati watching right now and my
beautiful wife Allie thank you to my
husband Matt to my kids my Cooper and
Miranda thank you for all the nights you
let me miss so I could pursue this crazy
career